Traductor: Ciro Gomez
Revisor: Lidia Cámara de la Fuente
Alrededor de 1159 dC,
un matemático llamado Bhaskara el Sabio
bosquejó un diseño para una rueda
que contenía depósitos curvos de mercurio.
Argumentó que al girar las ruedas,
el mercurio fluiría al fondo
de cada depósito,
dejando un lado de la rueda
perpetuamente más pesado que el otro.
El desequilibrio mantendría la rueda
girando para siempre.
El dibujo de Bhaskara
fue uno de los primeros diseños
de una máquina de movimiento perpetuo,
un dispositivo que puede
trabajar indefinidamente
sin ninguna fuente de energía externa.
Imagina un molino de viento que produce el
viento que necesita para seguir girando.
O una bombilla cuyo resplandor
proporcione su propia electricidad.
Estos dispositivos han cautivado
la imaginación de muchos inventores
porque podrían transformar
nuestra relación con la energía.
Por ejemplo, si pudieras construir
una máquina de movimiento perpetuo
que incluya humanos como parte
de su sistema perfectamente eficiente,
podría sostener la vida indefinidamente.
Sólo hay un problema.
No funcionan.
Las ideas para máquinas
de movimiento perpetuo
violan una o más leyes fundamentales
de la termodinámica,
la rama de la física
que describe la relación
entre diferentes formas de energía.
La primera ley de la termodinámica
dice que la energía
no puede ser creada o destruida.
No puedes sacar más energía
de la que pones.
Eso elimina de inmediato una
máquina de movimiento perpetuo útil
porque una máquina solo podría producir
la misma energía que consume.
No quedaría nada para alimentar
un automóvil o cargar un teléfono.
Pero ¿y si solo se quisiera que la máquina
se mantuviera en movimiento?
Los inventores han propuesto muchas ideas.
Varios de estas han sido variaciones en
la rueda sobreequilibrada de Bhaskara
con bolas rodantes
o pesos en brazos oscilantes.
Ninguno funciona.
Las partes móviles que hacen
más pesado un lado de la rueda
también desplazan su centro de masa
hacia abajo por debajo del eje.
Con un centro de masa bajo,
la rueda solo oscila hacia adelante
y hacia atrás como un péndulo,
luego se detiene.
¿Qué hay de un enfoque diferente?
En el siglo XVII,
a Robert Boyle se le ocurrió una idea
para una olla de riego automático.
Teorizó que la esa acción capilar,
la atracción entre líquidos y superficies
que tira del agua a través
de tubos delgados,
podría mantener el ciclo de agua
alrededor de la taza.
Pero si la acción capilar es tan fuerte
como para superar la gravedad
y elevar el agua,
también evita que caiga
de nuevo en el recipiente.
Hay versiones con imanes,
como este conjunto de rampas.
Como que la pelota es impulsada hacia
arriba por el imán en la parte superior,
cayendo a través del agujero
y repitiendo el ciclo.
Esta falla porque, al igual que
la olla de riego automático,
el imán simplemente mantendría
la bola en la parte superior.
Incluso si de alguna manera
se mantiene en movimiento,
la fuerza del imán
se degradaría con el tiempo
dejando finalmente de funcionar.
Para que cada una de estas máquinas
se mantenga en movimiento,
tendrían que crear
algo de energía adicional
para empujar el sistema
más allá de su punto de parada,
rompiendo la primera
ley de la termodinámica.
Hay algunas que parecen seguir adelante,
pero en realidad, invariablemente
resultan estar atrayendo energía
de alguna fuente externa.
Incluso si los ingenieros pudieran
de alguna manera diseñar una máquina
que no violara la primera
ley de la termodinámica,
todavía no funcionaría en el mundo real
debido a la segunda ley.
La segunda ley de la termodinámica
nos dice que la energía tiende a disiparse
a través de procesos como la fricción.
Cualquier máquina real
tendría partes móviles
o interacciones con moléculas
de aire o líquido
que generaría pequeñas cantidades
de fricción y calor,
incluso en el vacío.
Ese calor es la energía que se escapa
y que sigue escapándose,
reduciendo la energía disponible
para mover el propio sistema
hasta que la máquina
se detendría inevitablemente.
Hasta ahora,
estas dos leyes de la termodinámica
han obstaculizado cada idea
de movimiento perpetuo
y los sueños de generación de energía
perfectamente eficiente que implican.
Sin embargo, es difícil decir con certeza
que nunca descubriremos
una máquina de movimiento perpetuo
porque todavía hay mucho
que no entendemos del universo.
Tal vez encontremos
nuevas formas exóticas de materia
lo que obligaría a revisar
las leyes de la termodinámica.
O tal vez hay movimiento perpetuo
en pequeñas escalas cuánticas.
Lo que podemos estar razonablemente
seguros es que nunca dejaremos de buscar.
Por ahora, lo único que parece
verdaderamente perpetuo
es nuestra búsqueda.